entonces en este ejemplo que hemos
estado estudiando vimos como este banco
fue entre comillas rescatado
financieramente y fue rescatado por un
fondo soberano porque con se cumplió el
plazo de este préstamo se el banco no
pudo vender estos dedos por suficiente
dinero para pagar la deuda y no
consiguieron otro préstamo para pagar el
préstamo sé pero si lograron convencer a
unos extranjeros encantados con la marca
de este icono del capitalismo americano
hay que comprar algunas acciones de esta
compañía y esencialmente la rescataran
financieramente en el ejemplo solíamos
tener 500 mil millones de acciones y la
compañía emitió otros 2 billones de
acciones y los vendió a unos 50 por
acción obteniendo así 3 billones más un
billón que ya teníamos o sea ahora tiene
4 billones y así se puede pagar el
préstamo se y nos queda todavía un
billón de efectivo y ahora esta compañía
tiene un billón de efectivo más 4
billones de estos deseos que cree que
valen o sea 5 billones de activos
si es que realmente valen 4 billones y
no tiene pasivos así es que tiene 5
billones de capital no tenemos que el
capital no cambio cuando vendes algunos
de tus activos y obtienes la cantidad de
dinero que tú creías que valían y pagas
algunos pasivos el capital no cambia
pero qué es lo que pasó y solo para
acostumbrarnos a los términos la
compañía está completamente de esa plan
cada porque no tiene pasivos
crane o cero tiene de pasivos y sus
activos valen exactamente lo mismo que
su capital muchas compañías nuevas o de
tecnología tienen muy poca deuda o sea
estando está plantadas pero bueno este
es un ejemplo de un rescate financiero a
una compañía y quien perdió aquí pues
los accionistas perdieron antes sólo
había medio billón de acciones que se
dividieran este capital y ahora hay dos
millones y medio que sólo están
dividiendo entonces el valor libro de
estas acciones si crees que realmente
valen 4 billones bajó de 4 pesos a 2
pesos
pero que este es un paréntesis
importante como he dicho antes el valor
de mercado es a cuánto se venden las
acciones entre dos personas en el
mercado y antes nos preguntábamos cómo
afectaba este valor de mercado a la
compañía y bueno afecta a la compañía
cuando necesita recaudar fondos y eso es
lo que pasó en este ejemplo la compañía
necesitaba recaudar fondos y tuvo que ir
tal vez con el fondo soberano del
gobierno de singapur y decirle gobierno
de singapur por favor invierte nuestra
compañía compra nuestras acciones y
cuando el gobierno de singapur o
cualquier otro inversor quiere comprar
nuevas acciones usan el valor de mercado
como punto de referencia para determinar
cuánto pagar por acción muchas veces es
una situación desesperada y como esta
persona te está salvando pagarán menos
que el valor de mercado pero si dicen o
esta es una oportunidad de obtener una
gran cantidad de acciones y
esencialmente tomar el control de la
compañía podrían pagar una pequeña prima
sobre el precio por ejemplo pagar dos
pesos por acción en lugar de un peso que
es el valor actual del mercado
por eso es importante el precio de
mercado de las acciones en los mercados
secundarios donde las acciones se venden
entre personas que no tienen nada que
ver con la compañía porque cuando la
compañía necesita recaudar fondos el
valor de mercado se usa como el precio
justo bueno esta es la situación en la
que se rescata a la compañía qué pasa
cuando no la rescatan veamos esa
situación digamos que el fondo soberano
nunca ocurrió y déjame limpio todo esto
entonces nuestros activos
un billón de pesos en efectivo
y tenemos 4 billones de sede o
residenciales
con un total de 5 billones de pesos y
pasivos
o sea tenemos el préstamo sé que es el
qué
no se echó a perder todo con 3 billones
de pesos y tenemos un capital de 5
billones menos 3 billones 2 billones de
pesos
y eso está dividido entre 500 mil
millones de acciones o sea medio billón
de acciones
o sea que el valor libro por acción es
de 4 pesos pero no nos vamos a preocupar
por el valor de mercado de estas
acciones por el momento digamos que
todos estos fondos soberanos se quedaron
muy sacados de onda porque invirtieron
en citibank el año pasado y las acciones
siguieron cayendo en picada y también
invirtieron en merrill lynch todos
invirtieron y simplemente sigue cayendo
en picada y ya no quieren invertir no
quieren ser la última persona que se
queda con la papa caliente así es que
nadie está dispuesto a invertir capital
y entonces no mejora la situación los
dueños del préstamo se dicen ya no te
vamos a dar un nuevo préstamo y no
puedes pagar este porque si ven días
estos cd2 sólo te darían un peso por
ellos
así es que te voy a obligar a caer en la
bancarrota así es como sucede la
bancarrota cuando rompes un convenio con
alguien que te haya prestado dinero
estos convenios dicen que si no pagas el
préstamo mental periodo de tiempo o algo
le pasa a tus finanzas se te declara
insolvente y caes en la bancarrota y qué
sucede en la bancarrota
pues en la quiebra los tribunales de
quiebra toman la administración de todos
tus activos y dicen esto es lo que tú
tienes y bueno no nos vamos a meter en
esos detalles por el momento tal vez se
haga toda una serie de vídeos sobre los
detalles de la quiebra pero bueno tal
vez te den una especie de préstamo para
que continúes haciendo negocios porque
todavía no deciden si te van a
reestructurar sus pasivos o si van a
disolver la compañía porque ya no es una
entidad viable el chiste es que los
tribunales de quiebra se apoderan de la
administración supongamos que deciden
disolver la compañía entonces la dividen
entre los accionistas y las personas a
las que les debes dinero pero mejor
empecemos por el caso en el que no la
disuelven ok todos están de acuerdo en
que esta marca vale muchísimo sea cual
sea la marca o sea de goldman lynch el
imán sachs vale muchísimo y nadie quiere
ver que desaparezca entonces qué pasa
cómo caes en la quiebra pues las
personas a las que les debes dinero
tienen prioridad absoluta
entonces los del préstamo se escogen
primero sobre tus activos
y lo que quede se lo reparten entre los
accionistas entonces los dueños del
préstamo se dicen que quieren que este
banco siga funcionando porque les gusta
la marca pero que quieren tirar la
basura estos dedos y los tribunales de
quiebra dicen ok vamos a liquidar estos
dedos porque todos están de acuerdo en
que son muy turbios entonces los venden
y sólo obtienen un millón de pesos por
ellos así es que ahora hay 2 billones de
activos que además son 2 billones en
efectivo un billón que había antes más
el billón de vender los ceros
hay 2 billones y eso es todo nada tal
vez algunos edificios que no estamos
alistando aquí pero pues también está la
marca y a estas personas les deben 3
billones y dicen ok sabes que voy a
hacer que esta compañía siga funcionando
y esos 2 billones menos deben en mí y
voy a dejarlos ahí pero lo que obtengo a
cambio es esencialmente todas las nuevas
acciones de la compañía esencialmente lo
que van a hacer los tribunales de
quiebra es crear una nueva entidad
corporativa para poner todos estos
activos en ella y emitir otros 100 mil
millones de acciones o sea van a crear
una nueva entidad que tiene 2 billones
de activos de hecho son 2 billones en
efectivo
y digamos que no tiene deuda bueno tal
vez estas personas les presten dinero
porque pues estas personas ok no saben
que no quiero confundir las cosas
entonces no tienen deuda
así es que tienen un capital de 2
billones de pesos que hay 2 billones de
pesos y hay 100 mil millones de acciones
o sea punto un billón de acciones
entonces el valor libro de estas nuevas
acciones es de 20 pesos por acción y
podrías decir wow eso está genial
alguien pudo haber obtenido estas
acciones a un peso por acción y ahora
valen 20 pesos por acción pero no ese no
es el caso de hecho es algo terrible
estas acciones las acciones de la vieja
compañía valen cero porque cuando le
quieran la compañía bueno más bien
cuando valoran la compañía porque no la
liquidamos queríamos que siguiera
funcionando pero el valor de la compañía
al vender estos dedos es de dos billones
ya éstos les deben tres billones de
pesos entonces ellos dicen yo debería
quedarme con la compañía entera
aún así no estoy obteniendo lo que
merezco pero no va a quedar con toda la
compañía si es que quien haya hecho el
préstamo se ahora es dueño de todas las
acciones y los accionistas se quedan con
nada esas acciones valen cero y este es
un muy buen ejemplo porque he visto a
personas en la tele en las noticias
diciendo que buen negocio podría comprar
acciones de lehman brothers por un peso
pero ese no es el caso
díaz en que el limón brothers tiene
muchísimos activos y que nunca va a
desaparecer y eso puede ser verdad hasta
cierto punto pero los activos de lehman
brothers pueden ser menores que sus
pasivos sin ningún problema y entonces
su capital es negativo y pagar ese peso
no es un buen negocio si crees que el
limón brothers va a regresar
eventualmente lo que deberías hacer es
tratar de obtener uno de estos bonos y
cuando quiebre del otro lado la quiebra
terminarás conexiones del nuevo banco
que quién sabe cómo se llamará goldman
brothers o algo así en fin en el próximo
vídeo voy a juntarlo todo y mostrar para
empezar porque nuestro sistema
financiero se está congelando
y después que está intentando hacer el
rescate financiero del gobierno te veo
en el próximo vídeo